There's a lot going on here and
some of it we have not discussed before.
As an example,
the exclamation marks indicate these
are implicitly unwrapped optionals.
A concept in swift that you'll learn
in the UI kit fundamentals lesson
in a later part of the course.
Let's break down the audio
recorder code piece by piece.
You can see we first
import AVFoundation,
the framework that has
AV audio recorder.
Without this import, Xcode won't know
about any AVFoundation classes, and
our IOS app won't compile.
If we scroll down to the record
audio function, here,
we see what looks like the code
to get the directory path and
build a full path,
including the file name.
In the essence, this grabs the pitch
perfect's document directory and
stores it as a string in
the dirPath constant.
Later in this course,
when we get to persistence,
you'll learn the various directories and
storage locations available in IOS.
For now, we just need a place
to store the audio recording and
the documents directory
will work just fine.
A few lines down, we make an array with
the directory path and the file name.
Join those together and create
a URL to use with AVAudioRecorder.
We also print out the path so
you can see it in the console.
Next up, we grab the AVAudioSession and
set up the category to play and record.
In order to either record or playback
audio, we need an audio session.
There's just one that exists for
the entire time your app is running and
we grab it with a shared
instance method.
The AV audio session class is basically
an abstraction over the audio hardware.
Since there's only one audio hardware,
there's only one instance
of AVAudioSession.
You grab the shared instance that's
used by all apps on the iOS device.
This is a common pattern you
will find in cocoa touch.
When you reach into the iOS API and
grab a singleton, it is usually
a function called shared instance.
So with the AVAudioSession set up,
we can set up the AVAudioRecorder.
Here we see the line with
AVAudioRecorder inside of a try
statement, without handling if it fails.
We will cover error handling
later in this course.
For now,
we can just assume it will work.
We tell it to prepare recording and
start recording.
That's it,
AVAudioRecorder is now recording audio.